hey guys it is the 18th of februari my
name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games buddies you probably
already know by now that the US won't be
receiving the smaller new Nintendo 3ds
but now the publisher have come out to
explain why Nintendo of America's Damon
Baker told Nintendo life that the
company were worried that the smaller
new 3d s would have caused confusion for
it to be released in the US he explains
that it's important for them to give
consumers a clear idea of differences
between the two DS 3ds and new 3ds XL
acre explains quote the core audience we
weren't going to win them on that
decision but we had to think about
expanding the user base we had to be
able to market it and make it easy to
pick up for consumers while the new
Nintendo 3ds and new Nintendo 3ds XL
share the same technical specs the
regular sized model supports custom face
plates while the larger version doesn't
Baker said the faceplates asked super
cool but apparently not cool enough to
make up for all the confusion of
bringing the smaller new 3ds to North
America one would suggest that if
Nintendo really wanted to ensure
consumers could tell the difference
between their devices they shouldn't use
confusingly similar names like new
Nintendo 3ds and Wii U fool your
customers twice shame on you nintendo
the order 1886 dev ready at dawn us
still justifying their games length and
are now calling out the internet police
game director dana jan told develop
online that people are looking for
something to throw at our game some
reason to hate it i just feel like these
days it's so easy to be negative and i
think the internet is the new playground
for bullies he then went on to use a
glorious food metaphor to describe their
approach to quality versus quantity if
you go and you eat a steak if you pay a
hundred bucks for a steak that tastes
like the best steak you've ever had in
your life but it's only 200 grams this
is paying the same price for the worst
steak you could ever want but it's all
you can eat as an argument to be made
that one is better than the other
depending on who you are i mix
to hear what people who have actually
played the game think about it I think
by and large that most people are going
to be satisfied and today brings yet
another story that will have you
wondering whether or not you should
really drop money on that Kickstarter
and other projects being set to
disappoint back is the stomping land or
multiplayer dinosaur riddled survival
adventure was funded for a hundred and
fourteen thousand bucks even though it
only asked for 20 grand a first build of
the project landed on Steam early access
last year but despite promising it was
still being worked on and refined
everything about the game has been quiet
ever since now the game's art lead has
quit and the Creator alex pandora is not
responding to emails both funders art
lead and in-game bottle designer have
been unable to get in touch with pandora
kickstarter being Kickstarter has said
sorry to backers but that's probably all
they'll be getting out of the company
due to the at your own risk basis of
backing project let me know down in the
colors if you're still a Kickstarter
believer or not and why you can have to
gain spot we've got stories on soon
augmented reality glasses and not
talking yelling out to Microsoft that's
all I have to tell you about today i'll
have more new stuff for you same time
tomorrow but be sure they have a good
one until then
you